so you said you were a final Trigon how
was it like getting the job to re-adapt
Trigun so I was actually never expecting
to work on Dragon so it was actually um
I came in later in the project so my
friend my partner and friend producer
Rocky was the one who founded founded
the project Right and started but first
when I opened the book I mean I was like
everyone else I'm like what the [__] are
you guys doing
it's like don't touch a classic please
yeah there must have been some kind of
trepidation there where you hear like
you re you're re-adapting it like yeah
it was pretty good yeah kind of like a
bit of like I don't know if this is
gonna work
I mean when I I mean the more
information I knew about the entire
picture
um I was more comfortable with it right
right yeah right I mean as a um as a
first um project that how it started was
that it was the producers went naito the
original creator of trident himself and
saying that we want to make Trigun yeah
but naito was like well
I would love you guys to expand on it
not adapt it again right yeah yeah
actually it's already been adapted yeah
yeah what was like the philosophy when
it came to re-adapting a a show that a
lot of people held dear to their hearts
uh because there must have been a lot of
pressure on you guys to get this right I
mean we're all from I mean even director
himself we have kind of LinkedIn
lineage to try gun oh okay so the um
director's master was the triguns
director oh wow okay okay okay so we we
all of us have very special feelings to
the 98 Trigon yeah it's like I will
overpass you master
look at me yes as the ambition we
definitely had that oh yeah for sure as
it worked we're never intention to
re-rewrite everyone's precious memories
yeah but to be work along with it so I
mean it was very different from the
original as well in a lot of aspects I
think yeah I think it was really good it
was very different but I I you know I
feel like it was in a good way
um because I've seen enough remakes that
just try to redo everything like step by
step in like modern animation and I
really appreciated that you guys win a
completely different direction while I
think keeping the core of try again yeah
you kept the vibe for sure anime has had
a bit more success with remakes in
general than uh other mediums uh I mean
like Hunter Hunter and Full Metal
Alchemist but I mean
when you compare it to like how then
recently they announced that they're
remaking Moana in live action oh yeah
you ever you ever think man I
as a producer or Creator is there ever a
concerned with like is there going to be
too many remakes or are we going to be
making too many of these like I always
just wonder about that when you make
when you're working on a remake you're
like are we this is a good idea I don't
know yeah I feel I feel anime doesn't
have as much of a problem that like
Hollywood remakes have been going
through especially like Disney remix and
stuff like that yeah just because I
think we've learned from the past that
you know uh sometimes the remakes aren't
really worth it yeah you know and and I
feel like the most successful remakes
are the ones where at least in the anime
world are the ones where it took the
original Vibe and the concept and just
gave us something completely different
right like the reason why I like The
Fruits Basket remake was so successful
is because it did exactly that it took
kind of an incomplete story from the
anime and just kind of took all of the
parts that were wrong with it and just
improved upon it without changing the
vibe and it ended up being an amazing
remake so I feel like full matter
brother four mental Brother full metal
Brotherhood full metal
I've watched full metal yeah clearly for
myself Brothers
yeah I feel like after that just like
there was a whole wave of just like Oh
Santa was like the Remake is so good oh
yeah JoJo's technically a remake yeah I
guess so I guess so yeah okay I I want
to know without obviously spoiling
anything that you're working on now what
goes into the decision making of what
gets a season two and what doesn't get a
season two as an anime producer you
probably have the most uh perspective
about this I mean we get a lot of
request to make season two of course
yeah but I mean first we have to give in
the choice to make season two okay I
mean we have clients yeah so is the
client gonna give us a choice to make
season two right right I mean we I mean
so far if once we're given the choice we
always said yes so far yeah okay but
other projects um we haven't done is
that we don't have the choice to say it
yet right I mean maybe one day it'll
come by but yeah because it's it's
always so weird as an anime viewer you
see some of the things that are on like
their fifth season and then some fan
favorite shows cost like season one and
I'm like this this makes no sense to me
AKA data live and No Game No Life
is that just because the framework of
how an anime gets made is just so
complex with a lot of parties that get a
say and if it does or doesn't happen is
that the reason why I mean the the
business model is a very
um similar way but people involved are
all different yeah so it's really hard
to say what's happening I mean it could
be the original Creator it could be how
the business the producers are or it
could be the studio or there's a
complete other reasons so so uh the
Anime Studio only gets involved after
everything else has already been
approved or does Studio orange get to
you know be at the seat when shows are
being pitched for like not even like a
season two but just to be made in the
field like do you guys get to like
negotiating like we personally really
want to see a season two of this what do
you think kind of thing
um it depends on project project um
orange because we're CG based we have a
lot of limitations so like shows
involves 100 characters we can't do it
because that means equals a lot of
budget right right the business model
currently doesn't support that kind of
budget so there's no way we can get that
budget so why does increasing the
characters increase the budget so to
make one character it involves making a
CG model yeah which costs a lot of money
so making hundreds of that is equals
times that oh okay and that's why you
end up with the CG crowds where all the
characters just are the same model
because it's a lot cheaper right and
same movement as well yeah same movement
yeah exactly but by that logic when we
see some 3D and Anime uh into the anime
surely it would be more expensive than
the producer model and then animate that
model just for like one scene in anime
or is there some kind of cost cutting
method that makes more sense for that so
in our case um I can't speak for others
yeah yeah yeah but in Orange case that's
why we use still hand run characters as
well so in V Stars if you notice um
there's a lot of hand-drawn characters
yeah yeah one scene only characters okay
that's uh yeah I mean how much do you
put into like
let's say you let's say you were given a
series right and you still want to like
hand draw some scenes how do you choose
which scenes you want to like hand draw
versus which scenes you want to like
keep completing in 3D it totally depends
on what can we do in 3D right so if the
3D is going to explode into 3000 pieces
um then in that case our bfx team is
very excellent so they could they'll say
they could do it okay but if it's going
to let's say split into 100 characters
right then our animation team says that
we can't do that oh okay okay so how big
is your team in terms of like your let's
say 2D animation kind of like like
specialty we currently have about over
100 employees oh so every year we have
about
um 20 employees trying to extend the
studio right we think that's the limit
of how we could train people right okay
okay
um and I guess like you I I guess I'd
like to learn know more about
you know you have your own like journey
into the anime industry but
if say someone's watching this right now
and they were interested into getting
into the anime industry maybe as like a
producer or any other kind of role what
is like now that you've been here for
like 10 10 odd years what's your like
advice to people who actually want to
get into the animation in this room
yeah it totally depends what you want to
do in this industry if you want to be an
animator then just start drawing and
then if you haven't drawn you start
drawing just apply to any studio right
we have a lot of shortages in this
industry so I won't say um I can't speak
for other Studios so um I can't say for
their working condition
but I mean if I please find the good
working condition partner to work okay
okay